نستعرض عناوين اهم الصحف التركيه الصادره
هذا اليوم يوم السبت اي قبل موعد
الانتخابات بيوم واحد نبدا بصحف المعارضه
صحيفه سوس جو وهي صحيفه معارضه تقول ان
تركيا تحت احتلال اللاجئين ايضا صحيفه
جمهوريه وهي من الصحف المقربه من حزب
الشعب الجمهوري المعارض تقول الديمقراطيه
او الديكتاتوريه بالنسبه للصحف المواليه
للحكومه نبدا بصحيفه حريات والتي قالت
انتخابات سهله ونتائج سريعه بالنسبه ايضا
لصحيفه يني شفق وهي ايضا من الصحف المقربه
لحكومه حزب العداله والتنميه قالت الثامن
والعشرين من مايو لا مجال للتعويض في
اشاره الى رئيس الوزراء التركي الاسبق
الذي اعدم وهو عدنان مانديرس واخيرا مع
صحيفه تركيا وهي ايضا من الصحف المواليه
تقول قرار القرن في اشاره الى ان هذه
الانتخابات الانتخابات حاسمه